we've covered the healthcare systems of
Singapore Germany the United Kingdom
Canada and a lot of other systems
Switzerland and France which have
slightly different health care systems
and there's a really interesting case
study which is that of Taiwan which
someone on our subreddit mentioned and
I've been researching for the last
couple of days the Ministry of Health
and Welfare runs health care in Taiwan
meaning that health insurance is
government-run and the current system
was put in place in 1995 so it's sort of
recent compared to other systems that
countries have that have been around
much much longer and as of 10 years ago
Taiwan had about 99 percent health care
coverage with their system and the
health care premiums are paid through
the payroll tax shared by employees and
employers and that is actually similar
to the United States there's a split
employers pay part of it and employees
pay part of it but it goes towards a
government-run single-payer insurance
system rather than each company sort of
figuring out which for-profit health
insurance carrier than what they want to
use it's heavily subsidized so if you
can't pay because of poverty if you're a
veteran there are no financial barriers
to ultimately getting the care that you
need
under the Taiwanese system but the
providers are still mostly private in
other words the the health care
providers are not government-run such as
through a national health care system
like what we see in the United Kingdom
and there have been significant
reductions to the disparities in health
outcomes between the rich and the poor
or the haves and have-nots since this
system was implemented very low spending
per person in Taiwan long life
expectancy in Taiwan low infant
mortality rate in Taiwan and the
question is that what when we consider
all of the different proposals that
exist in the United States single-payer
nationalizing health care all of these
different possibilities what I think is
really important to understand and it's
sort of depressing to have to under
sandesh I'm not married to one
particular way of expanding healthcare
coverage to everybody in the United
States Medicare currently has some
issues so while Medicare for all would
be way better than the system we have it
doesn't have to be the one solution but
all of the systems that these modern
countries have implemented they all are
better than the system we have in the
United States they are systems with far
less waste
they are systems that cost much less to
get the health care people need to them
on a per capita basis and they are
systems that increase access as a
percentage of the population some of the
critiques we hear when universal
coverage systems are put in place
include if all of a sudden everybody has
coverage and they're not paying for
individual services at the point of sale
people are going to overuse their health
insurance and get procedures that they
don't need that's absolutely ridiculous
and what we have seen in Taiwan is that
yes healthcare usage has increased
because everybody or all but one percent
of the population now have health
coverage but what that means is when
people have symptoms they go to the
doctor when it's time for your annual
checkup people go although in modern
United States health care law those
annual checkups have to be offered a
copay free so the right likes to pretend
that if people don't have to pay for
each service they get they're going to
overuse health care which is laughably
ridiculous getting health care services
isn't a hobby and people don't go out
and just get procedures that they don't
need nor do doctors perform procedures
that are not medically necessary
you'll get preventive care that helps
prevent expensive treatments in the
future by virtue of preventing disease
and the biggest problem that Taiwan is
having is actually that they don't have
enough doctors and nurses relative to
the size of the population but still
sadly by sort of overworking the doctors
and nurses that they have they've
managed to have relatively few wait time
issues but it's not great to have to
overwork your doctors and
nurses this reminds me of the bazaar
exchange during Bernie Sanders Town Hall
on Monday with Martha McCallum and Bret
Baier where Martha McCallum said
someone's paying for it either way
whether it's paid through deductions
from your paycheck or whether it's paid
through taxes or whether it's from your
employer or not someone's paying for it
either way and this is sort of exactly
the point health care is not free money
doesn't grow on trees either way we're
paying for it
why don't we eliminate many of the cost
inflationary mechanisms in the system we
have medical billing code coders who
work for the providers medical billing
coders who work for the insurers health
insurance fraud investigators management
consultants for insurance companies who
are looking to make money the profit
which is only two or three percent for
insurance companies but still adds up if
either way someone is paying for it why
don't we get rid of all the stuff that
we don't really need pay less and get
more someone's paying for it either way
let's pay less isn't that the obvious
direction we should be going and Taiwan
is just again one of another of the
dozen or 15 or maybe even 20 examples
around the world that are all slightly
different from each other but all better
and more effective than in the United
States if you love learning new things
you probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
skill share and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to skill
share when you click the link underneath
this video skill share is a vibrant
online learning community offering more
than 25,000 video classes on just about
anything you can think of get better at
playing an instrument learn to use
Photoshop how to edit videos they have
classes on drawing painting business
cooking nutrition personal productivity
and I'm not even really scratching the
surface I recently took a great class on
introductory watercolour painting I'm
still not good but I am learning and you
can access the entire library of fun
easy-to-use online courses for free for
two months
by using the link underneath this video
two months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video